[Music]
on this Friday night the NHL's top boss
on the record about the hockey Canada
sex assault case aorn reprehensible
horrific and unacceptable and how Gary
bman got on the
defensive breaking news the US begins
its retaliatory strikes to avenge the
deaths of three
soldiers bringing Ukrainian children
home it is a matter of Our Own own
Humanity Canada's new efforts to reunite
families ripped apart by Russia's
War global national with faren Asser
reporting tonight niku Gara good evening
and thanks for joining us for the first
time since five former and current NHL
players who were part of Canada's
winning 2018 World Junior hockey team
were charged with sexual assault the NHL
commissioner Gary bman has weighed in to
take a handful of players uh in this or
other situations and use those
allegations and condemn a particular
sport I don't think is reflective of
what we are the players are preparing to
appear in court on Monday their lawyers
say they deny any wrongdoing and will
all plead not guilty the five men are on
leave but have not been suspended by the
NHL and the League's commissioner
confirmed today they are still receiving
pay bman says he needs to wait for the
judicial process to play out before the
league takes action Eric senson has our
top story
tonight the allstar game is the NHL's
promotional spectacle but with a cloud
of criticism overshadowing its big
weekend commissioner Gary bman set out
to defend the league as four players and
a former NHL now face charges of sexual
assault from the moment we first learned
about this on May 26
2022 I have have repeatedly used the
words abor reprehensible horrific and
unacceptable to describe the alleged
behaviors the alleged behaviors date
back to 2018 five players from the world
junior hockey championship team were
accused of sexually assaulting a woman
in a London hotel room after a hockey
Canada Gala it has been almost 6 years
bman said the NHL did not finish its
investigation before the charges were
laid it's taken us about the same amount
of time to get to this point as it took
the London Police Service and this was
the second time they were investigating
it the five players were all drafted by
NHL teams and became part of the star
studded culture of hockey which some
critics say contributes to sometimes bad
behavior bman wasn't having it I think
any characterization that this is a
systemic issue is both inaccurate and
unfair
99.9% of the players certainly in our
league conduct themselves appropriately
The Players Association echoed those
sentiments and would say little more you
know 99% of the players in the league
that you know you don't have issues but
again these players uh are innocent are
proven guilty as many youngsters lined
up in Toronto for a glimpse of the NHL's
best the League's commissioner had a
message of reassurance if you're
associated with this game either as a
young player or the family of a young
player we believe you can and should be
comfortable that this game has every
intention of being welcoming inclusive
and safe as an environment for people to
participate the accused NHL players have
taken a leave of absence from their
teams and while not suspended they will
all be free agents at the end of the
season and highly unlikely to be
resigned as the legal process plays out
the five men are set to appear in court
in London on Monday and police will hold
a news conference in the afternoon Eric
senson Global News
Toronto also today the NHL announcing
the League's top players will be able to
compete in the Olympics again starting
in 2026 the last time nhlers competed in
the Winter Games was in Sochi in 2014
where Team Canada won Gold the league
pulled out of pong Chang in 2018 due to
travel and insurance costs along with
marketing rights the NHL did not allow
players to participate in the 2022
Beijing games due to
covid-19 breaking news in the Middle
East the US has now launched air strikes
on Iranian backed militias all in
response to the deadly drone attack that
killed three soldiers at a US military
base in Jordan last weekend today's
strikes targeted dozens of sites used by
the militias in both Syria and Iraq
after the Biden Administration warned
there would be retaliation Reggie Chini
joins us now from Washington Reggie what
do we know so far hi need to since
Sunday when President Joe Biden said
quote we shall respond we've known
something was in the works although
details were a bit nebulous beyond the
talking point that these Iranian proxies
deemed responsible for this drone attack
last Sunday needed to be held
accountable but it's a difficult
Balancing Act well the US has been clear
it doesn't want a broader war with Iran
these groups are connected militarily
and financially with tan so what do we
know well 85 targets were struck by
numerous aircraft including the
longrange B1 bomber with us Central
Command saying these were command and
control centers intelligence centers and
weapon supply lines and we're hearing
from Syrian state television that these
strikes have been deadly it is
noteworthy that this response came just
hours after Biden attended the dignified
transfer of the three service members
killed in Sunday's attack now President
Biden has been under pressure from some
Republicans who argued he wasn't moving
fast enough but this is a moment that
carries potential political consequences
this is an election year and the
president has been steadfast in his
position of not having the US drawn into
a broader Middle East war and while the
White House confirms tonight that
strikes will continue at times and
places of its choosing they say it's not
expected to be within Iran
yetu Reggie Chini in Washington thanks
Reggie calls for transparency within
Canada's intelligence Community are
growing following a global news report
which found cus had urged the liberal
government to do more to fight foreign
interference prime minister Justin
Trudeau says his government has taken
action but questions are being raised
about why they didn't act sooner Abigail
Bean
reports this is a one-bedroom accessible
unit touring waterl Ontario Friday the
Prime Minister was focused on housing
while Canada's spy agency wants the
government to take more action on a
different matter a top secret cus report
obtained by global news says until it
views foreign interference as a quote
existential threat and forcefully and
actively responds those threats will
persist it is indeed an existential
threat to democracy we have taken action
and we will continue to take action we
wanted to the top secret briefing was
for the minister of democratic
institutions who spent Friday morning in
the hot seed at the public inquiry into
foreign interference people need to
understand the nature of foreign
interference that the threat is real the
inquiry looks at foreign interference in
the 2019 and 2021 elections and the vast
majority of documents have not been
released publicly due to their top
secret nature foreign interference uh
especially with ch
China is uh the whole Iceberg itself and
what we are looking for is a tip of the
iceberg Dominic LeBlanc was questioned
on the need to protect National Security
versus the importance of transparency I
wouldn't describe it as a as a tension
it's a balance we may see a situation
where the commission really won't be
able to tell us what they know about uh
what's been going on with Chinese
interference activities in Canada among
those calling for more transparency a
lawyer for former liberal MP H dong we
will do everything we can to cooperate
and help you achieve your mandate
through transparency separate from the
inquiry dong filed a defamation suit
against Global News and our parent
company chorus entertainment relating to
global news reporting that two
independent National Security sources
said dong had a conversation in 2021
with the Chinese Consul General in which
dong raised the cases of Michael COV and
Michael spavor and allegedly advised
China to delay their release dong denies
the allegations and calls the stories
malicious irresponsible and defamatory
allegations in the statement of claim
have not been tested in court he has had
a
career of that has been
derailed by what has happened and he has
a life that's derailed as well the first
week of public hearings for the inquiry
has now wrapped up the second of three
weeks will be held in March Abigail Bean
Global News Ottawa the immigration and
Refugee board has ordered the
deportation of a senior Iranian
government official who has been living
in Canada for the past eight months
Majid Iran Manesh was director general
of Iran's vice presidency for Science
and Technology he came to Canada last
May using a Visa issued in Turkey he
said he intended to spend a year at the
University of Victoria as a visiting
professor in November border officials
flagged his case alleging he was still a
senior official of the Iranian regime
the 54-year-old is the first to face
deportation under sanctions adopted at
the end of 2022 which banned senior
Iranian officials from Canada you can
read more about the case and the eight
other alleged Iranian officials facing
deportation on globalnews.ca global
national in Su BC police are
investigating a shooting that targeted
the home of of a sick activist and a
friend of murdered gvar president hardip
Singh nider niger's death last year
prompted accusations the Indian
government was involved in the killing
sparking questions over whether this
incident was related Emily littin is at
the
scene Neu the shooting happened here in
a South Ser neighborhood the home
targeted just five houses down in this
culdesac behind
me local guara members say the target of
Thursday's early morning shooting is a
well-known member of the sick Community
simet Singh returned to his home early
Thursday morning minutes later shots
were fired outside a white Tesla damaged
by gunfire the home riddled with bullets
the shooting also extended to a bedroom
upstairs where his six-year-old son was
sleeping uh and it missed it went
through his headboard and missed his
head by about a foot fortunately no one
was injured in this shooting and we are
working with the family and they're
cooperating the count Council says Singh
was a friend of pro calistan activist
hardip sing ner he was shot and killed
in broad daylight outside Su Guru naaki
gwara last June we fun fundamentally and
wholeheartedly believe that this is
India for that reason is that they
killed of deeping niter here and they're
after people that are as Close
Associates prime minister Justin chido
accused the Indian government agents of
killing niter inflaming tensions between
the two countries India has denied
responsibility and allegation
the Indian government is trying to
silence and kill vocal dissidents that's
somebody firing 20 bullets into his home
um in the middle of the night it just
shows to us that this is what India
would do to frighten or warn or strike
fear into the hearts of sixs and
activists Canada go to India last year a
US indictment revealed law enforcement
thwarted a murder for higher plot
targeting a Canadian American citizen
and sick activists living in New York in
a statement gerat want sing panu says in
part Canada's failure to dismantle and
crack down Indian spy networks operating
from Indian Missions has enabled the
Modi regime to continue with
transnational repression against Pro
calistan 6 in Canada following this
latest shooting three prominent Canadian
sick groups are now demanding standing
in the federal inquiry on foreign
interference sir RCMP believ the
shooting is an isolated incident we're
told that Singh feared for his life that
in recent months he believed he was
being followed and reported seeing
suspicious cars outside his home Neu
Emily littin in sui BC thanks Emily he
went from the grd iron to Hollywood you
take this home throw it in a pot add
some broth the potato baby you got a
stew going The Versatile career of Carl
Weathers
Canada's foreign affairs minister is in
keev to launch a new campaign aimed at
returning thousands of Ukrainian
children deported by Russia's military
it is Melanie Jolie's fourth trip to the
conflict Zone since the start of the
fullscale invasion she says Canada's
support for Ukraine's independent future
is unwavering Crystal ganing has more on
the surprise visit as the war approaches
its 2-year
Mark outside of Ukraine and Russia
Canada has the largest Ukrainian
population so it's no surprise melan
joli was back in the country offering a
new kind of support Canada and Ukraine
will launch a new International
Coalition to bring back Ukrainian
children we will work with Ukraine to
help develop a consular case for each
child identifying and returning
illegally deported children has been a
top priority for Ukraine's first lb
exactly how many children have been
taken isn't known but it's believed to
be in the thousands children have been
used as props at Russian rallies
propaganda to support their claim that
the so-called special military operation
is rooted in Russia saving
ukrainians that campaign the Russian
defense minister to his colleagues
included more than 120 strikes on
Ukraine last month alone strikes that
can continue to be concentrated on
communities in the East Russia recently
floated the idea of creating
demilitarized zones in some areas it
occupies in Ukraine a red herring
according to the US if Russia really
wanted to show interest in a
demilitarized zone the thing they could
do is start by demilitarizing the parts
of Ukraine where they're currently
Russian forces on the heels of a
historic European Aid package which
Hungarian prime minister Victor Orban
stalled Orban said Ukraine will only get
weaker the longer the war drags on and
more people will
die Ukraine has no plans of giving up
and Canada was praised for its continued
support what can we say about Canada you
know everything about Canada Canada is
our closest friend since Russia's
full-scale Invasion Canada has pledged
more than 9 billion including 2.4
billion in military aid Jolie visit to
Ukraine did not come with more financial
support Crystal ganing Global News
London ahead how the high expectations
of Canada's International students are
clashing with tough
realities we are pausing the levels at
the level they are uh over the next two
years to ensure at 2023 levels to make
sure that every student who comes here
gets the right experience which includes
uh adequate and Supportive Housing uh
but also a range of other things that go
with a quality
education that is prime minister Justin
Trudeau defending his government's new
two-year cap on International students
something that could pose a big
Financial hit for postsecondary
institutions International students are
a significant source of funding for
colleges and universities and that's
often prompted enticing recruitment
efforts to attract them to this country
but they often mask the difficult
realities they have to face once they
get here Mike drle explains so hello
guys welcome back to my channel from his
Toronto area apartment Ashish baa dishes
out advice his target audience
International students many of whom see
videos like these I see my uh G Vis and
believe visas to study in Canada are
easy to get Bia says recruiter is
working independently of Canadian
colleges and universities are selling a
dream have you seen a Punjabi music
video driving those nice cars you know
having that Challenger and or do charger
with them uh the mindset usually becomes
that it doesn't take long he says for
reality to set in high tuition costs
work restrictions and an oversaturated
rental house housing market have forced
some students into difficult living
conditions so what will happen they will
have multiple people living in in one
two-bedroom apartment like six seven
people it's a familiar story here in
Kitchener water supply of rental units
has not kept up with demand just a few
years ago a unit that would get five or
six applicants now gets 30 to 40 last
week's announcement that would cap the
number of international student visas
was made in part to address the housing
crisis Ontario for one will see 50%
fewer new students easing demands on
housing but taking much needed money
away from a sector that's getting less
Public Funding than it used to the way
forward would be for um colleges and
universities to uh punch up and not down
right don't blame International students
don't blame the students don't blame the
kind of low-wage workers that are on
campus the scapegoating is a concern but
Bia also worries what will happen in
India when the promises of easy visas
are harder to keep but what happens when
you put a threshold on something
competition Rises and then eventually
you know uh corruption also plays a
really important role then solving one
problem say critics could create a
bigger crisis altogether Mike trle
Global News Kitchener waterl
Ontario mysterious shipwreck next awe
over an ancient vessel in New Finland
and
[Music]
Labrador
I've been with the best and I beat the
best I've retired more men than Social
Security that's actor Carl Weathers in
one of his best known roles Apollo Creed
in the Rocky franchise he died yesterday
at the age of 76 his family says he
passed peacefully in his sleep before
his 50-year acting career weathers
played professional football including
for the cfl's BC Lions the nominated
Stars span genres from Hit comedies like
Happy Gilmore and Arrested Development
to sci-fi franchises like Star Wars and
Predator there's something about an
ancient shipwreck that captures the
imagination and the Mysterious
appearance of a wooden vessel possibly
from the 19th century on New Finland and
labrador's southwest coast is playing on
everyone's Minds experts are digging
into the ship and its origins in
collaboration with Renee Roy from wck
House Press tonight we bring you a
closer view of the wreck and more on
what people are doing to keep it from
being swept back out to see here's Heidi
petrack every day locals flock to see
the mysterious shipwreck partially
visible during low tide at Cape
Ray but it's from the air that the view
is truly spectacular Drone footage
showing the mass of wreckage believed
dislodged from its watery Grave by
powerful post tropical storm Fiona more
than a year ago ocean currents doing the
rest and I've been down here spend four
five 6 hours hours every day watching it
make sure that nobody's touching it
lifelong Cape Ray resident Bert Osman
stands behind what's known as a ship's
knee part of its Stern all the debris
now considered a protected provincial
archaeological site overwhelming man
that's the first time this stuff been
seen in probably 200 years right
concerned the tides could sweep it all
back out to sea divers Shawn bath and
Trevor Croft helped secure the wreckage
using tethers to keep it in place she
knock down on 12 right provincial
experts from the other side of the
island almost 900 km away are heading to
the site to inspect it firsthand we'll
be able to see what kind of wood that
the Shipwreck is made of what size the
Timbers are uh measure them up to see
how long they are from that we might be
able to figure out uh where it came from
they believe it dates back to the 19th
century but plan to test the wood to
find out for sure and then fill in the
pieces of the story of where that ship
came from who was on it when it was
Shipwrecked at Cape Ray in a province
known as The Rock This Coastal Community
is no stranger to shipwrecks Supply
ships passed by regularly for 300 years
and storms brought at least a dozen down
but this this what many Now call the
ghost ship has made that seafaring
history come to life it's full story a
mystery yet to be revealed Heidi pic
Global News
Halifax and that is global national for
this Friday night I'm Nara tonight's
your candada is the SS key weiten docked
in Kingston Ontario we love seeing your
Canada please email your photos to
viewers
global.com thanks so much for watching
and hope you'll join us again tomorrow
have a great great
[Music]
night